well i'm joined in the studio by justin
crump a military expert and chief
executive of the intelligence fern
sibiline uh first of all justin what
what's the current situation around the
sever donetsk area yeah i mean obviously
still very focused on that as the the
key part of the fighting and uh russian
troops closing in on the city we think
there's around two and a half thousand
defenders uh principal in the area the
industrial area around the as a chemical
plant with around 500 civilians also in
that area so kind of shades of what
happened to mario paul
smaller scale
and they're not completely cut off so
though the river the bridges have been
uh destroyed as far as we understand
there are still ways to get across
certainly for people probably not heavy
equipment so
the fighting continues it's a real grind
for russia here but they are steadily
gaining ground in the city at this point
so if we zoom out a bit uh what what
does that tell us
the real fight i mean it's amazing in
the way that that ukraine's still
hanging on in severe donetsk it's the
wrong side of the donetsk river as you
can see there and the more defensible
position is mr chance gets the other
half of the city effectively on the high
ground uh on the correct side for
ukraine or the river but the problem
they've got is that russia's trying to
cut them off they've failed in the past
but they're going to keep trying they'll
keep trying to cross the river up here
uh they'll keep trying to come out from
porpasner now that's stalled in the past
but they're keeping pressure on there
and in depth so actually as you go
towards isiam and the major cities in
depth here for ukraine so you can see
that defending this area there's a lot
to defend and russia can concentrate
forces where it needs to over time and
if they do break through elsewhere it
makes it very hard for ukraine to hold
that very far eastern end of this area
and that's one of the big challenges for
them now we heard from deborah about
nato and about the u.s announcement as
well about 800 million uh in weapons
these are some of the examples is it
going to change anything in terms of the
bigger picture there's no silver bullet
in this um but to put this in
perspective ukraine's asked for around a
thousand artillery pieces i think
they're getting 18 on the current pledge
they've asked for 300 multiple launch
rocket systems they're getting three
from the uk three from germany four from
the us um so in terms of the scale of
what they want to be able to have parity
with russia and to be able to eventually
counter attack regain territory they are
vastly short of that and every round
they're firing at the moment is coming
from nato it's going to travel across
the country should be fired so there's
quite a bit of work to be done i think
if the commitments we're hearing in kiev
today are going to be met with really
meaningful support for ukraine to win
okay justin thanks very much